so i want to talk a little bit about the
books i've been reading i feel like i
haven't been talking much
about what i've been reading because
i've just been making
stupid uh nonsense i have been reading
actual books
i'm not illiterate as some people in the
comments have been suggesting
let's dive in shall we oh before i start
follow me on twitter the friends of
eddie coyle which is
an old crime novel i believe it's from
the 1970s
and was turned into a movie with robert
mitchum i haven't seen the movie
i heard that this was an inspiration for
my man mr
elmore leonard he said he read the
friends of eddie coyle and it taught him
how to write dialogue and i was like
i want to learn how to write dialogue
yeah it's pretty much all dialogue it
kind of reads like a play
sometimes hard to get into and figure
out what's exactly going on but once you
do once you get a sense of who these
characters are
the story unfolds all the characters are
horrible they're just like do crime and
then are racist in boston i mean it
wasn't my favorite read
interesting parts and the most
interesting part was just how it was
written there's not much
action described it's just conversations
yeah it was enjoyable
oh i finished uh the wolves of the cali
i have a
review on my channel uh already you can
check that out to see what i thought of
the fifth dark tower book
moral of the story it was good the next
book this may have been my favorite read
of this batch
no surprise it wasn't elmore leonard
this is one of his earlier books
and it is a western 40 lashes less one
the only notoriety it has i think is
that quentin tarantino
purchased the film rights tarantino
adapted um
rum punch into jackie brown this book is
fascinating a prison in
yuma in the early 1900s explores the
dynamics of you know racism and there's
a new prison warden who is very
religious who's trying to teach the
troubled prisoners
about god basically it's a real like
um revenge story just fun
interesting characters a lot of drama it
just has a great
ending one of my favorite like final
lines in a book
elmore leonard can just get straight to
the heart of a scene
there's some brutal scenes but it's a
fun exciting book it's like uh
tarantino django in prison sort of 40
lashes less one
i've been kind of into older noir
this book kind of popped up on my radar
because i heard
other crime writers talking about how it
was really good
it's called black wings has my angel by
elliot chase you know it's very like
archetypal you know you feel there's not
a lot of elements in it that are very
new
but the way it's written is really
beautiful the language is just
clear but also really lyrical in a way
that
doesn't distract from the narration who
is it's narrated by this you know
criminal who's a murderer and i don't
really know how to describe it
basically about this ex-con who um
falls in love with an ex-prostitute they
come up with the plan for a crime to rob
a bank they have a very
twisted disturbing relationship with
each other
kind of hateful love really beautiful
dark
haunting yeah this one's going to stick
with me for a while it's just
it was very sad in some ways so the last
book i finished that i want to talk
about is a
science fiction book this is one i've
heard about mainly because it's sort of
infamous
it has very graphic content but it's
like a space opera so it's very
unexpected in some ways the whole
story of the book is about the abuser
and the victim and the rescuer
operatic drama that unfolded and what we
expect to happen is unexpected really
disturbing
i can't recommend it to a lot of people
and you'll see like if you
go on goodreads like a lot of people are
like wow i could not read this book how
could anyone read this book i think it's
because
in the genre of like science fiction
especially space opera you're not
expecting something this incredibly dark
mixed with like
action and adventure in space you know i
mean at its heart it's a character study
of a really twisted deranged
monstrous human anyways the book is
called the real story
by stephen r donaldson who made his way
to
fame by writing the thomas covenant
series
i don't know how many people are
familiar with the the gap series but i
found
the first book the real story to be
different and fascinating i thought the
world
the ideas were really interesting it was
really grim dark
grim dark in outer space exploring
characters who are
massively massively evil diving into
this
headspace that is really uncomfortable
very graphic
i was just totally engaged the entire
time i had to know what happened
the voice of the author was so strong
and fascinating the world was
unique and bizarre but there wasn't just
pages and pages of world building
it's just a book unlike anything i've
i've read in the science fiction genre
i i really loved it and i'm going to
continue reading the series i believe
there's five books
it's not for everybody please like read
reviews before you go in look at content
guidelines real quick i uh dnf'd swag i
read about half of it that's an elmore
leonard
novel um i dnf'd it just because i'd
been reading a lot of elmore leonard i
felt like i knew where it was going
i do want to finish it but i just ran
out of time on the library
with the library homage to catalonia by
george orwell i got this because i
wanted to do some
to see if there was any research i could
get out of this because i
for the book i'm writing i found it
interesting in a really
enjoyable read and fascinating but it
didn't turn out to help
my research very much at least not the
beginning of it so i think i'll finish
it
one day though uh next up blue of noon
by georges bataille i read
the story of the eye by georges bataille
recently
so i picked a blue of noon really
interesting story
about a dark twisted romance a little
confusing
but i wanted to see where it went but
again i just
lost interest a little bit halfway
through the last dnf i have here is
the tunnel it was definitely well
written for its time it was like
revolutionary in its style and its
frankness
very self-conscious very rambly
i didn't hate it but i just found it
annoying i feel like i've read
other stuff in this kind of narrative
voice felt like i wanted to mention it i
don't know if anybody has read
the tunnel if they they suggest i should
finish it or not but
that's kind of like a reading update i
don't really do a lot of these but
anyways i have a lot of books i'm
planning on reading soon
good stuff uh coming up a lot more
fantasy i'm gonna start some new series
and
see what happens so thank you all for
sticking with me and watching i don't i
don't really know what else to say have
a good one